now we've been talking about how
gorgeous the weathers can be and you
might be thinking let's take a hike but
but be warned Red Rock has been tweeting
out that rattlesnakes were spotted at
their Visitor Center Laura negretti is
on the lookout and she joins us live
from out at Red Rock this morning with
the Rattler report good morning Lauren
watch your step out there okay
oh for sure
thank you but yet without a department
of but we are in rattlesnakes
October top just like uh yeah apparently
there's a little signal problem out
there but I think she was talking about
uh rattles Rattlers go into the shade to
get out of the heat too and they've been
doing that out at Red Rock Canyon as
well Sherry that means they kind of go
into hiding and they're in crevices and
Red Rock Canyon staff offer a few tips
that you should be aware of your
surroundings never put your hands or
feet in places where you can't see if
you're out there hiking and if you see a
snake leave it alone if you're hiking
with your pup it's best to keep them on
a leash and keep them on the trail with
you so they want you to look into
rattlesnake avoidance classes for your
dog they do have a few dog trainers
nearby so uh what's the general rule of
thumb Sherry well the staff advises that
you bring plenty of water and wear the
right shoes and clothing and there are
some spaces out there where cell service
is not very good we just saw that yes so
you can see that so coming up what to do
if you're bitten and Laura negretti will
try to get the signal straight out there
and give you that live report Heather
and John coming up